everybody thank you thank you again for
the introduction I'm Shelly I'm a
software engineer at github working on
open source today I would like to do a
deep dive into the mechanics of
asynchronous programming in JavaScript
to make sure we're all on the same page
before I really get started I'll go over
basic principles of async then we'll
launch into the different methodologies
and the nuances of what exactly
differentiates them and then finally
we'll compare over the spectrum of
options to discuss which situations
require which approaches let's say you
have a program contained within a single
file it's made up of functions and at
any given time only one of these is
going to be executing now the rest will
execute later at some point in the
future that there is the crux of async
it's the relationship between now and
later and the way in which you manage
this relationship with your code what is
key here
however and what causes some of the most
difficulties for developers when they're
just starting out is that later does not
mean strictly and immediately after now
it could be at any point in the future
and you don't necessarily know when that
will be now let's move on to some of the
technical underpinnings of how code is
executed in the JavaScript environment
in pursuit of this understanding it's
best to start with the event loop the
event loop can best be conceptualized as
an endlessly running singly threaded
loop where each iteration runs a small
chunk of code in the program if you
wanted to run a chunk of code at a later
time that chuck would simply be added to
the queue for the event loop and when
the time came that you desired it to
execute it would be DQ'd and executed
with es6 came a new concept called the
micro task queue but we'll save that for
a little bit later
it's also important to mention that
javascript has what's known as run to
completion semantics this means that the
current task always finishes before the
next task begins or until it explosively
yields control back to the event loop as
a result of this each task has complete
control over all current state and does
not need to worry about another task
modifying things at the exact same time
looking at the code here running this
will always print first and then second
because the function starting in set
timeout is audited the task you
immediately but is only executed after
the current piece of code is done since
it yielded control now let's take a look
at the call stack when a function foo
calls a function bar bar needs to know
we're inside foo to return to after it's
done this information is managed with
the call stack take a look at the set of
three functions on the left hand side of
the slide and let's walk through how the
stack will look as the program executes
initially when the program above is
started the call stack is empty after
foo is called the stack has one entry
location in global scope so that as I
mentioned before foo knows where to
return to when it's finished next after
bar is called the stack has two entries
it's now store at the location that bar
needs to return to when it's finished
executing in addition to global scope
the trend continues as Baz is called and
the stack now contains Baz's return
address as well as the previous return
addresses from previous function calls
when console.log is called in Baz the
call stack is printed to console next
each of the functions terminates and
each time the top entry is removed from
the stack after foo is done we're back
in global scope and the call stack is
empty
at the end we return and the program is
terminated in looking at this you can
see a handful of the things I previously
mentioned the event loop the task queue
and the stack the current task comes off
of the event queue and its location is
stored in memory where all relevant
variables populate the heap the task
queue is populated by tasks sources any
one of which would be a particular chunk
of code in an executing program this
snapshot would represent the moment
after the all functions in the previous
slide had executed and before locations
had begun to pop off of the stack most
of you have likely encountered pull
backs so I'm going to focus more on how
they fit into the async landscape as a
whole let's start by looking at some
functions and discussing them in context
here you can see I have two programs
side by side on the left the function
names are alphabetical from top down and
on the right side I've mapped the
functions to the order in which they run
most likely your eyes have to do a
significant amount of jumping around in
order to discern the order in which the
functions are executing for the program
on the left since they're not running in
the top-down sequential order in which
you might expect by following the
cardinal number words on the right side
you probably had an easier time so let's
talk about why that is your brain
operates sequentially which places it at
odds with the inherited functionality of
Kolbe X this is a comparatively simpler
example but when callback starts in next
significantly you enter what's known
colloquially as callback hell which
becomes progressively more difficult for
your brain to reason through what's
happening here in terms of the call
stack and by extension the event loop
assuming all these functions are async
first we'll begin and then immediately
do control and then second we'll execute
a callback was registered by first so
the next available task will be back
callback next third will execute
followed by fourth fourth registers a
callback and then returns control so
that fifth execute the callback
registered by fourth will come off the
cui the queue and execute and then
finally sixth will execute for each of
these functions taking a callback the
callback itself is a black box for the
function the continuation of the program
is dependent on our handing that
callback off to another part of the code
and then essentially just praying that
it'll do the correct thing when the
callback is invoked this paradigm is
known as inversion of control and can
create significant trust issues in the
previous code snippet I had up you could
see that your eyes had to skip around
even though they most likely wanted to
read the code in a top-down fashion when
you sometimes struggle to understand how
and when each part of a piece of code is
working it's undoubtedly hard to deal
with errors in that code within the
callback landscape there are two ways in
which errors are reported via callbacks
and via exceptions you need to be
careful to combine both properly this is
because the most obvious but
occasionally overlooked aspect of
dealing with errors in callbacks is to
make sure that they've actually all been
handled however there's a caveat to this
advice and it lies specifically and how
errors are caught can you see how in the
snippet above I returned and did he
throw an error that was intentional
because exceptions are only a
synchronous mechanism which is logical
in an asynchronous environment the
exception could be thrown and when the
handler block is already out of scope
the error would be rendered meaningless
the next big innovation in asynchronous
programming promises hit javascript with
es6 before this there was no direct
notion of async built directly into the
JavaScript engine all it ever did was
execute a single chunk of your program
at any given moment when asked to you
the developer asked it to by means of
callbacks or timeouts in order to
shuffle its place in the event loop with
promises came a change to the Jas engine
which took a form of the cue I mentioned
very briefly at the very beginning the
micro task you before I delve into how
exactly this changes the form of the
stack cue event loop diagram I showed
you a few slides ago let's look at an
example of a program utilizing promises
and then discuss what's happening and
why promises act as placeholders they
allow us to reason about future values
without necessarily knowing their
outcomes making them functionally
extemporaneous when the future value is
settled it might succeed or fail and
then at that point the promise is no
longer a placeholder and becomes an
immutable value a few slides ago I
referenced the paradigm known as
inversion of control where we handed off
callbacks and just hope they did the
right thing promises confer to us a
capability to know when a given task
finishes and then our code can decide
what to do based off of those results
importantly promises may seem like an
entirely different paradigm but in fact
they don't get rid of callbacks at all
they just change where the callback has
passed to and remove the black box
effect we saw previously we get back
from a function the ability to know when
it's completed and then perform new
tasks from there
as I said promises are not just the
mechanism for single step operations
that follow with this then that flow
they're capable of that of course but it
turns out that we can string multiple
promises together to represent a seek
of async steps visibility is conferred
to us as a result of two key
characteristics of promises which are
that one every single time you call Ven
on a promise it creates and returns a
new promise and to the value returned
from the dot vans call calls fulfillment
callback the first parameter is
automatically set as the fulfillment of
the chained promise looking to the slide
by returning hello world we fulfill the
promise that the first dot ven call
created and returned when the next dot
then call runs its receiving the
fulfilment from the return hello world
statement the second dot then would
create then another promise so how does
this look under the hood promises
utilize the micro task queue which
allows us to say here is this thing that
I need to do later but I need to ensure
it happens immediately later before
anything else can happen the micro task
you can best be thought of as attached
to each tick in the event loop some asic
actions will be added to the end of the
current ticks micro task queue instead
of creating a whole new tick in the
event loop queue as a whole when
promises are resolved or rejected the
associated handlers will be called
asynchronously as micro tasks and then
added to the queue for the current tick
this diagram looks nearly identical to
the diagram I showed you a few slides
back with one key difference the
addition of the micro task queue once a
promise settles or if it's already
settled accuse a micro task for its
reactionary callbacks this ensures
promise callbacks are async even if the
promise has already settled so calling
that van with resolver reject against
the settle promise immediately queues a
micro task any additional micro tasks
queued during a given micro tasks are
added to the end of the queue and also
processed
so in looking at the diagram you'll see
that the current task can come off the
task queue or the micro task queue all
promise callbacks are queued as micro
tasks a micro task can also cause one or
more micro tasks to be added to the end
of the same queue so it's theoretically
possible that a micro task loop could
spin indefinitely the starving the
program of its ability to move on to the
next event loop tik
this would conceptually be almost the
same as expressing an infinite loop in
your code what happens if something goes
wrong in a promise how do we deal with
those errors by default it turns out
promises are silently swallowed if
they're unhandled more specifically any
exception which is thrown inside a dot
then within a dot down handler or within
a function passed to a new promise will
be silently disposed of unless manually
handled the standard way to handle
errors from promises is to add a catch
handler at the end of your promise chain
you can also change these handlers so
you can throw errors into progressively
more outer level scopes catching andrey
throwing errors in this way will tell
you what led to the error more
effectively so that you can later debug
the issue more efficiently if exceptions
are thrown inside the callbacks of Deven
and dot catch it's not necessarily a
problem because these two methods
convert them to rejections let's look at
an example and talk about what would
work and what wouldn't in more concrete
terms this is a simple promise example
and from looking you can see that prom
is going to reject with an error no
matter what so what happens in the first
example versus the second the first has
a catch so it's going to print the error
followed by the error message which in
this case is rejected you can also see
the associated call stack by printing
error dot stack the second one doesn't
have a catch
so even though it threw an error it'll
simply fail silently
this next type of async approach
generators sits a little on the edge of
the overall async landscape but is
nevertheless important to touch on the
first thing to observe as we talk about
generators is how they differ from
normal functions there are several
notable differences but key to
generators is their behavior with
respect to the run to completion
expectation with generators we have a
different kind of function which can be
paused in the middle either once or
several times it is resumed later a
which allows other code to run during
these pause periods between runs the
main strength of generators is that they
provide a single threaded synchronous
looking code style but allow us to hide
the asynchrony away as an implementation
detail this lets us express naturally
what a program step and statement flow
is without how to navigate the
asynchronous gotchas and syntax at the
same time to get a better idea of how
this looks in practice let's see a
function here you'll see immediately
that there's a little star next to the
function in the signature this is the
syntactical indicator that you're
looking at a generator function the
keyword yield will send out a value
whenever the function is run so here the
yield index plus plus expression will
send the index value out when pausing
the generator function at that point if
ever the generator is restarted whatever
value is sent in will be the result of
that expression which will then get
added to one and assigned to the index
variable when we start index is zero so
this will be yielded and then one will
be added to index as a result of the
plus plus this will occur each time as
the value of index is passed out and
then in again and so that it increments
by 1 every time to see this a little
more clearly let's look at a
diagrammatic representation on the left
you see a traditional non generator
function it adheres to the run to
completion
we expect from functions with no
interruptions from beginning to end on
the right is the generator function with
multiple stops and starts between
beginning and end it's important to note
that there's no real official end per se
and a generator function the end in this
case would just be the last time that
yield is called when the generator
function is initialized an iterator is
returned and then the generator starts
with the first call to next on the
function this function pauses when yield
is called and then would restart with
the next call to next and so on and so
forth to recap with normal functions you
get parameters at the beginning and a
return value at the end but generator
functions you send messages out with
yield and you send messages back in with
each restart one of the most powerful
parts of es6 generator design is that
the semantics of the code inside a
generator are synchronous even if the
external iteration control proceeds
asynchronously that's a fancy way of
saying that you can use a very simple
error handling technique you're probably
familiar with the try-catch mechanism
even though the function will pause at
the yield 3 expression and may remain
paused for an arbitrary amount of time
the try-catch will catch it with normal
async capabilities like callbacks that's
almost impossible to do the generator
itself also has a throw function to
throw an error into the generator at its
pause position which of course can also
be caught by a try-catch inside the
generator async await is a new way to
write asynchronous code previous options
are callbacks and promises async await
was created to simplify the process of
working with and writing chained
promises and so async await functions
themselves return promises they cannot
be used with plain callbacks async await
is thus like promises non-blocking and
makes asynchronous code look and behave
more like synchronous code this is where
all of its power lies since any async
await function returns a promise
implicitly the resolved value of the
this will be whatever you return from
the function to illustrate let's look at
code here we're returning a string that
contains several components of a street
address the function has the async
keyword before it and the await keyword
can only be used inside functions
defined with async all four variables
must be resolved before the function
will return the desired string also
important to note here is that if we did
not use the await keyword but for each
of the address component functions this
function would not necessarily fail it
would just mean that the variables would
be set to promises instead of the values
returned from them there is also an off
- overlooked gotcha
I'd like to point out here before I move
on which is that await calls operate
sequentially what this means is that the
call to get city won't kick off until
after we have a value forget street
address in some cases this desired
behavior such as when one call depends
on the results from a previous call here
however we want to get all these address
components simultaneously so we
shouldn't be blocking each on the
previous one instead we should rewrite
it like this under the hood a single
wait works almost exactly the same as
promises utilizing the new micro task
you introduced to handle async
operations if you're familiar with
promises you know that if a promise is
rejected you need to handle that error
inside a catch and if you're handling
errors for both synchronous and
asynchronous code you will likely have
to duplicate your error handler in the
above snippet we can see that there's
duplicate code on line 6 and Latinate
the catch statement on line 7 will
handle any errors that the synchronous
function do synchronous things may throw
but it won't handle any errors thrown by
do something since it's synchronous or
since it's asynchronous
my apologies this example may seem
palatable since all it's doing
is printing the air to console but if
there's any kind of complex error
handling logic we want to avoid
duplicating it async/await
lets us do exactly that by looking at
the code snippet on the top right you'll
see that we only catch once when we use
async/await we can catch errors from
both synchronous and asynchronous
actions in a single handler here we can
both minimize the total amount of code
that we write and catch errors in a more
readable and clearer way so wrapping up
our brains plan things out in sequential
blocking singly threaded semantic ways
but callbacks Express asynchronous flow
in a rather nonlinear non sequential way
which makes reasoning properly about
such code much more difficult call backs
suffer from lack of sequentiality and
lack of trust ability but they're good
in situations where you may just keep
performing a simple request that's
always asynchronous they're just plain
functions so they also don't require any
additional understanding beyond knowing
how asynchronous operations work they
also tend to be more for bus so
coordinating multiple asynchronous
requests with them concurrently can lead
to haulback hell if you're not actively
modularizing your functions dealing with
errors also tends to be more confusing
since there could be many error objects
that all go back to a single error
further down the call stack promises are
easier to reason about although they
still have their downsides they're
especially useful for coordinating
multiple asynchronous operations
propagating errors from nested async
operations and dynamic weight chaining
asynchronous operations ie those where
you would do something a sync examine
output and then do something else
a cing based on the intermediate values
errors and error stacks and promises can
also be a challenge
because they can behave unintuitive ly
in the way in which they print errors
when those errors are thrown they
brought new changes to the JavaScript
engine and pave the way for later
innovations like async/await this latest
async pattern is essentially saying
tactical sugar on promises but it allows
for more intuitive reading of
asynchronous code it also improves error
handling compared to traditional
promises and can be handled with simple
try-catch blocks it's so easy to use
async await that one of its slight
dangers is that you forget that you're
writing asynchronous code at all
ultimately the best tool to use for a
job is going to be the one that's most
specific to the job that you're doing
but now I hope you'll have a firmer
grasp on what exactly makes each of
these tools a best fit for certain jobs
and be able to use them with the deeper
understanding of what's going on at a
granular level thank you very much
[Applause]